>> Tucker: ALMOST SINCE THE
DAWN OF CIVILIZATION CASH
MONEY HAS BEEN A CRITICAL
PIECE OF THE ECONOMY.
ANCIENT TIME GOLD AND PAPER
COINS.
TODAY PAPER MONEY REMAINS
THE MOST SINGLE POPULAR WAY
TO MAKE TRANSACTIONS IN THIS
COUNTRY SHOULD IT BE SOME
ECONOMISTS SAY DAY-TO-DAY
SHOPPING CAN EASILY BE DONE
ELECTRONICALLY CONTINUED USE
OF CASH HURTS THE ECONOMY
AND MAY EVEN CAUSE CRIME.
KENNETH IS THE HARVARD
PROFESSOR, FORMER CHIEF
ECONOMIST AT THE
INTERNATIONAL FUND.
FORWARD TOWARDS A CASHLESS
SOCIETY.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: I HEARD THIS
ARGUMENT BEFORE AND I
AND THE POSSIBILITIES FOR
CRIME, TRANSNATIONAL CRIME
IT AVAILS TO CRIMINALS.
I GET ALL OF THAT BUT THERE
IS ALSO A SUSPICION THAT A
LOT OF US HAVE THAT
ELIMINATING IT WOULD JUST
INCREASE GOVERNMENT POWER,
MAYBE TO A POINT THAT'S
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SO, I ACTUALLY DON'T FAVOR
BILLS LIKE THE 50 AND THE
100 AND SIMILAR AROUND THE
WORLD.
I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE
USE OF CASH, ACTUALLY, BY
QUANTITY OF TRANSACTIONS
IT'S NOWHERE NEAR THE MOST
POPULAR.
IT'S FALLEN OUT.
IT'S BEHIND FOR PURCHASES
OVER, YOU KNOW, $50 IT'S
FOR SMALL PAYMENTS IT'S VERY
CONVENIENT.
OF COURSE SOMETIMES SOMEBODY
WANTS TO DO SOMETHING FOR
5,000, EVEN $100,000 THEY
DON'T WANT ANYONE TO KNOW.
BRIEFCASE OF $10 BILLS
$100,000, 20 POUNDS IF YOU
HAVE TO DO THAT ONCE IN A
WHILE.
WE SHOULDN'T GO CASHLESS.
BUT I DO THINK IF YOU LOOK
AT THE DECLINING USE OF
CASH, AND THE RISING
PRINTING OF THESE BIG BILLS,
WE OUGHT TO REALIZE IT'S FOR
TAX EVASION.
THAT'S MUCH BIGGER THAN
CRIME AND CRIME AND IF YOU
CAN CUT BACK ON TAX EVASION,
YOU COULD, FOR EXAMPLE,
LOWER TAX RATES.
>> Tucker: SO YOU DO
INSTINCT, DESIRE FOR
PRIVACY.
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY WANT
ANYBODY, WHETHER IT'S A BANK
OR THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT
TRACKING WHAT THEY ARE DOING
WITH THEIR MONEY AND THAT'S
OKAY, YOU THINK?
>> WELL, THERE IS A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOMEBODY
DOING A WHOLESALE BUSINESS
WHERE THEY ARE DOING 50,000,
WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO KNOW
AND, YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY WHO
IS DOING SOMETHING ON A MUCH
SMALLER SCALE.
AND I THINK THESE WHOLESALE
TRANSACTIONS ARE FACILITATED
BY THESE BIG BILLS.
BIG, YOU KNOW, DRUG
KINGPINS, TAX EVASION IS A
RECALIBRATE IT A LITTLE BIT.
NOT SO MUCH ELIMINATE IT.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU WORRIED
ABOUT THE VULNERABILITIES OF
DIRECTION ANYWAY.
THE BEAUTY OF CASH IS IT'S
TANGIBLE.
YOU CAN HIDE IT UNDER YOUR
BED.
NO ONE CAN HACK $100 BILL.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
THAT?
>> I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
CYBER SECURITY.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IF WE
HAVE A PROBLEM HANGING ON TO
THE RUMP OF CASH WE HAVE
IF YOU HAVE A BIG STORM,
THAT KNOCKS OUT THE POWER
SYSTEM, GOD FORBID AN EMP
BLAST OR SOMETHING.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> IT'S VERY USEFUL TO HAVE
SOME RUMP OF CASH LEFT
THERE.
ALTHOUGH, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN VERY INVENTIVE
WHEN THAT'S HAPPENED IN THE
PAST WITH CHECKS IOIS AND
OTHER THINGS.
WE DON'T WANT TO GET RID OF
CASH COMPLETELY.
I DO THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
WHAT THE GOVERNMENT IS
EVERY MAN WOMAN AND CHILD IN
THE UNITED STATES.
AND THERE ARE LOTS OF
COUNTRY.
THE AVERAGE PERSON IS
HOLDING, YOU KNOW, MAYBE A
MUCH LESS THEIR KIDS.
>> Tucker: NO, THEY ARE NOT.
QUICKLY WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
BIT COIN?
WHERE DOES THAT FALL IN THE
SPECTRUM.
>> BIT COIN IS GREAT
INNOVATION.
THE PARTY OF IT EVENTUALLY
THE GOVERNMENT HAS TO APPLY
ANTIMONY LAUNDERING RULES.
TAX RULES AND OTHER THINGS.
LET PEOPLE DO GIANT
TRANSACTIONS, TRANSNATIONAL,
NATIONAL, AND NOT CARE ABOUT
IT.
COIN IS GREAT TECHNOLOGY BUT
IT'S MORE LIKELY TO LOOK
LIKE MYSPACE THAT LOST OUT
TO FACEBOOK.
THAN IT IS TO LOOK LIKE THE
NEXT BIG THING.
THE GOVERNMENT IN THE END.
AND YOU NEVER WIN
THREATENING THE GOVERNMENT.
>> IN THE CURRENCY GAME, THE
GOVERNMENT MAKES THE RULES.
SO THIS IDEA THAT YOU CAN
INVENT A CURRENCY THAT WINS
OUT, IT'S NONSENSE.
OF IT THOUGH.